I think the penultimate scene I think
everybody comments is as the hairdresser
scene and only I know how we work that
scene we were in actual hair salon and
sigh and I would retreat to a closet the
service closet of the hair salon and she
would sing her song that reminded of her
mother and she had I'm telling them a
secret that the person you're in love
with the love of your life is your mom
and but those exchanges every in between
every setup to realize how important
this story was because it not only was
the sense of conflict between mother and
daughter here between side chin and
talent Amita as actors but whenever I
went through with my own mother and
whatever any of these women with their
daughters or children go through so I
knew that the story was universal and
knowing how extremely important it was
to get it right and I didn't get it
right because I looped that scene right
wing because Waverly is the [ __ ] of the
film and she played it like a [ __ ] in
the film and Wayne wanted to soften it a
little bit so weary looped it and much
to his advice and his success and his
patience with me we got that damn scene
right and it really really still carries
and it was the scene that ends the
window and Waverly seemed set so I'm
really very thankful for divulging your
private feelings